bienvenu merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors pensez vous
que cette demande des parlementaires
algériens à va aboutir
on sait que joe biden est offensive sur
la politique internationale qui changent
de direction par rapport à donald trump
mais sur la question du sahara
occidental finalement on n'en sait pas
grand chose pour l'instant question je
dirais que c'est le plan du principe
j'espère aussi que jordan ou reviendra
sur la décision du président trente et
une en sortant je l'espère de tout mon
coeur parce que voilà c'est au plan du
principe il y à il y a le droit
international et c'est ce qui doit
primer mais malheureusement ça ne suffit
pas il ne faut pas être naïf alors cette
décision donal 30 à quel point la pasta
n'est pas une situation disons l'eau
déjà très tendu la décision de donald
trump vient apporter une phrase solution
un vrai problème et je dirais pour ma
part que le droit international n'a
jamais avoir résolu des problèmes à
l'horizon et n'intervient à chaud quand
les conflits éclatent
aussi je pense que les les peuples du
maghreb doivent doivent trouver une
autre solution par heure de même moi mon
avis le préjudice causé par ce conflit
qui dure depuis quarante cinq ans et que
l'onu n'a pas réussi à régler il faudra
appeler je ne vois pas comment elle
pourrait le régler même si joe raedle
revient sur la décision du président
tram j'ai mon avis laquelle là dessus
bien sûr je ne je vous le dis moi
prévalence et si vous le souhaitez oui
ah bon avant de parler de votre avis
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de conflits
en afrique elle celui autour du sahara
occidental dure depuis longtemps vous
l'avez dit depuis plus de 40 ans un
conflit en tout cas qui perd 6 certains
diront même qui s'est détériorée
puisqu'on sait qu'il ya eu les
agressions dans la zone
tampon finalement on en statu quo
désormais avec peut-être le risque d'une
guerre nous parler d'une communauté
internationale qui ne faisait pas grand
chose mais at elle vraiment une marche
de manoeuvre pour résoudre ce conflit
écoutez mon avis est que le pas plus que
pour les vélos votre famille le droit
international ou l'onu n'ont pu régler
le problème il a fallu que le conflit
éclate ou que en un an puis ce que pour
que l'onu était réel et encore vous
allez vous rappeler dans quelles
conditions
s'agissant du conflit du sahara
occidental qui date depuis 45 car il
faut rappeler ce conflit ne peut être
réglée contre voisins et sur les bases
qui sont des bases d'intérêts communs à
long terme sur la base de leur
intégration
c'est à dire une solution offre au fond
où tous les peuples de la région seront
gagnés ont signé de saada mais les
marocains et les algériens et les
tunisiens et les marocains
bref tous ces peuples là sont affectés
par ce conflit qui empoisonne la région
qui entraîne un préjudice énorme une
course aux armements qui dissipe les
ressources de ces pays
et puis j'aimerais aussi insisté sur un
facteur c'est que ces pays-là serait
deux fois plus riche aujourd'hui toute
la région et le coût d'une dune on
échange beaucoup de lan wan intégration
entraîne un préjudice pour tous les
états pour tous les peuples
il faut peut-être revenu à la sagesse
des peuples et à nevers une solution par
le haut c'est à dire une solution par
l'intégration régionale cette solution
permettrait de faire que tous les pays
soient gagnants mais évidemment il
faudrait que ce la solution vienne de
ces pays eux mêmes
moi à mon avis on ne réglera à cette
question pas plus leur et les pays
étrangers à la région
il faudrait que les pays du maghreb se
mettre d'accord pour sortir du cadre
national chauviniste je dirais étriqué
chacun voit se voit ses intérêts à
l'aune de ses frontières
cette rente sert nationale on le sait
aujourd'hui c'est absolument faux aucun
de ces pays ne peut se développer tout
seul et encore moins en tournant le dos
à ses voisins donc il faudrait être
imaginatif donner la parole
m parce que manifestement les élites
dirigeantes de ces pays ont échoué
évidemment les appels pour autant qu'on
leur donne leur demande leur point de
vue je rappelle qu'il n'y a jamais eu de
référendum de consultations sur cette
question ni au maroc ni en tunisie ni en
appui chacun défend ses intérêts je
dirais nationale chauvinisme existent
eux m'en donner la parole au peuple fait
vite fait par rapport à un référendum de
tourneur d'autodétermination justement
pourquoi ce référendum est bloqué mais
parce que ce référendum est basée sur
des intérêts de chaque état de chaque
nation
les intérêts étriqués ce que j'appelle
nationale chauvinisme en fait tout se
passe comme si on ne voyait que chaque
pays ne voyait que ses intérêts
immédiats ses intérêts propres sans voir
que la solution de ce problème pourrait
aisément être trouvée dans un cadre plus
large par abandon sous progressives de
souveraineté on le voit à l'union
européenne parce qu'au même moment les
communes de frontières pas de douane etc
et bien c'est tout le contraire qui se
fait au niveau du maghreb et c'est la
raison pour laquelle conflit n'est pas
réglé parce qu'on postule et un postulat
qui qui qui est qui et qui est seul clic
sur lequel on se base et qui était que
l'intérêt national doit primer l'intérêt
national marocain d'intérêt national
l'international algérien
à mon avis c'est une fausse solution et
il suffit simplement de d2 regarder plus
loin d'aborder le problème sous un pont
dans un compte en son contexte régional
vont s'apercevoir que finalement ce sont
les pays de la région et aucune entre
qui peuvent régler le problème
ce qui est de nature à permettre à ces
pays de se développer et dans 1 et 2 de
prospérer dans un cadre de paix pour en
finir avec l'insécurité et l'instabilité
parce que voyez-vous ce conflit-là
engendre dans seulement 1 en
développement un retard dans le
développement mais elle entraîne aussi
des tensions de temps
de toutes sortes qui pète précisément
accentue ce retard de développement en
scannant des investissements et en
dissipant les ressources de ce pays là
alors très rapidement monsieur à benoït
pour qu'on comprenne bien finalement la
décision de donald trump parle de
reconnaître la souveraineté du maroc sur
le sahara occidental ça n'a pas vraiment
de valeur juridique
non seulement sa nano juridique mais ça
n'est pas une solution parce que le
ténéré le problème 30 au fond l aise une
partie elle prétend avantages et notre
parti mais en réalité elles n'avantage
ni le maroc ni le sahara ni les faits ni
les pays voisins c'est une fausse
réponse à un vrai problème
ali benouari merci à vous d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes ancien ministre algérien
président du parti politique ni da el
watan mercier